WORKING TO CONVENE IS A SEVEN
COMMITTEE SEEING AS WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD A SIMILAR MEASURE
EARLIER THIS YEAR IN THE
COMMITTEE IS ALREADY FITTED
THIS POLICY SO. WILL OPEN UP
THE HEARING THIS MORNING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THEN WHEN WE
GET A QUORUM WILL WILL CALL THE
ROLL BUT WHEN IT IN IN THE
INTEREST A TIME WHEN A ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PARA QUE AND TO
PRESENT AND HER STEAM
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SENATE SO
WELCOME. AND GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER. CHAIR HAPPY
TO BE HERE AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US DESPITE THE LATE
NIGHT. TODAY WERE HERE WITH AB.
TEN EIGHTY SIX A BILL THAT'S
FAMILIAR TO ALL THE HEARD
EARLIER IN THE YEAR. IF THE
DISTRICTS BILL THAT'S BEEN
AMENDED TO CLEAR UP AMBIGUITY
AUTHORIZING BUT NOT REQUIRING.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS TO SELL THE ALAMEDA TEST
LIKE STANCHION AREA. OF THE
CARNEGIE STATE VEHICULAR
RECREATION AREA AREA IF THE
SALE IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE PUBLIC. AND THIS IS A RICH
BIOLOGICAL AND CULTURAL AREA AT
THE SALE OF THE LAND WOULD
PROVIDE ECOLOGICAL PROTECTIONS.
AND CONTINUE TO ALLOW VISITORS
TO ACCESS THE LAND. AS A BILL
STATES THE LAND SHOULD NOT
SHALL NOT BE SOLD FOR LESS THAN
THE ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE.
AND THE PROCEEDS OF THE SALE
SHALL GO TO THE OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE TRUST FUND. ALSO WHEN I
CONTINUE TO NOTE THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT IMPACT THE EXISTING
OFFERED VEHICLE PARKED. THAT IS
NEXT DOOR THE CARNEGIE VEHICLE
PARK. THE BILL ENJOYS BROAD
RANGE OF SUPPORT INCLUDING THE
SIERRA CLUB. COUNTY OF ALAMEDA
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
SOCIETY OF AMERICAN INDIANS.
AND THE NORTH VALLEY YOU'VE GOT
STRIVE AND THE NOTICE HOMINY
CULTURAL PRESERVATION. I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF BEING HERE AND I WILL OPEN.
TURN IT OVER TO MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS I.
JOIN BY SENATOR BOB I. CASKEY.
WHO HAS GREAT PASSION THIS
ISSUE OUT YOU'VE HEARD THIS
BILL PREVIOUSLY. AN ALMOST
EXACT FORM THAT'S YOUR TODAY
AND IT ONLY PROVIDES ADOPTION.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING I THINK
WOULD BE HEALTHY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND REC TO
HAVE IN THIS CASE WHAT SUCH A
CONTROVERSIAL AREA. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SIR WELCOME CENTER
CASKEY. RELEASED IT. I JUST
WANT TO UNDERSCORE ITALICIZE
AND HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE
THAT THIS HAS TO THE REGION
IT'S NOT JUST STILL LOCAL PARK
IT'S REALLY REGION IT'S A STATE
ASSET. AT THE END OF THE DAY
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYBODY IN
THE STATE'S ENJOY THESE
CULTURAL AND NATURAL RESOURCES
AND I WOULD. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD URGE AN IPHONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MEMBERS WE
CAMINO SUBCOMMITTEE ALLOWED
PRESENTATION WE HEARD IS THE
EXACT SAME BILL OR THE EARLIER
THIS YEAR BY SENATOR GLAZERS
SO. OPENING PRESENTATION JUST
COMMENCED. AND NOW WE WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM OUR SUPPORT. SIX
WHAT YOU HEARD EARLIER. ALL
THREE OF THE LEGISLATORS.
EXPRESSED SOME EXPECTS TO THE
ATTIC SUPPORT FOR THE BILL AND
THEY UNDERSCORED HOW
ECOLOGICALLY VALUABLE DISPUTE
HI AREA IS FOR THE COMMUNITY
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE. TO
EMPHASIZE. OF THAT ON TESLA'S
BIOLOGICAL IMPORTANCE IS
IRREFUTABLE ITS LOCATION AT THE
INTERSECTION OF BIOTIC ZONES
RESULT IN RARE ABOUT DIVERSITY
IN SERVICE SERVICES SPACE
SPECIES SAVINGS CORRIDORS AND
BUFFERS AND TIME OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. HAS FORTY TWO SPECIAL
STATUS AND WILDLIFE SPECIES
THIRTEEN SPECIAL STATUS IN
TWENTY EIGHT LOCAL RECORD
REALLY PLANT SPECIES AND SEVEN
SENSITIVE VEGETATION
COMMUNITIES. THESE SENSITIVE OR
RARE NATURAL CULTURE RESOURCES
COVER NEARLY THE ENTIRETY OF
TESTS LANDSCAPE. THREE LAYER
UPON LAYER OF AREAS THAT MUST
BE PROTECTED WITH NO DAMAGING
WHICH FEW RECREATION USE. WILL
THERE ARE DIFFERENT VIEWS ABOUT
WHICH THE RECREATION USE BUT WE
MISS ALL AGREE THAT THERE ARE
SOME PLACES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE THAT'S NOT
NECESSARY OR APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERING. THE ECOLOGICAL
DIED. AFTER RESOURCES. AND SO
THAT I WOULD URGE YOU TO. I ON
THE SPECIAL THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT. MR
TURN MEMBERS THE SILENCE ELLIS
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
AND CONTINUED AND ONGOING
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO EXPRESS THE
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY AS WELL
AS- ON CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR OTHERS.
ACCORDING TO MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU STOOD ON
BEHALF THE LARGEST PARK.
DISTRICT IN THE CONTINENTAL U.
S. EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER TURNOVERS
MODICUM ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
OKAY THANKS SO MUCH. LET'S SEE
NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF ANY IN
OPPOSITION. WELCOME MR MCCAIN I
THINK MAYBE WE DON'T MIND
FREEING UP THANK YOU SENATOR.
YES. OKAY GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING WELL CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TERRY MCHALE
WITH ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING A COALITION OF OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION IS.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THE ADVICE OF
BILL CRAVEN WHO TOLD ME TO DO
THREE THINGS THIS MORNING. HE
SAID FIRST OF ALL SAY SOMETHING
NICE ABOUT SENATOR GLAZER. I
CAN TELL YOU THAT'S A VERY EASY
THING TO DO HE HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY RESILIENT THIS IS
THE THIRD TIME. THAT WE HAVE
SEEN THIS BILL. HE IS AN
OUTSTANDING THE INDIA HAS TO
FIX LOOKING BETTER AND BETTER.
SECOND OF ALL BILL SAID BRIEFLY
EXPLAIN WHY YOU ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. SENATOR GLAZERS AN
EXCELLENT LEGISLATOR. THIS IS A
BAD BILL IN THIS IS A BAD BILL
FOR TWO REASONS FIRST OF ALL
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME YOU'VE
HEARD IT AND THE REASON IT
HASN'T PASSED BEFORE IS NOT
BECAUSE THERE'S A REAT
AFFINITY FOR V I RECOGNIZE
THAT IT'S ALWAYS LIKE
REPRESENTING THE RED HEADED
STEP CHILD. BUT THEY DO A GREAT
JOB AND WE'VE RUN LEGISLATION
ONLY EIGHT OF THE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PARKS ARE OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE RECREATION PARKS. THE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS SAYS THAT WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE WAY
TO BE. IS A NATIONAL EXAMPLE OF
HOW TO DO IT RIGHT. WE HAVE
MORE SCIENTIST WORKING ON A WAY
TO BE THAN ANY OTHER PART OF
THE PARKS. WE HAVE MITIGATION
PROCESS I SAW THAT THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN STAFF ALSO WANT TO SAY
THIS ONLY WHEN STAFFERS BEEN
GREAT TO DEAL WITH AND I
APPRECIATE THEIR COURTESIES.
THERE'S PICTURES IN WHICH WE
SHOW THE DAMAGE THAT EIGHT FEET
DOES. THE TRUTH IS THERE'S TWO
TRUTH TO THAT ONE IS THAT THOSE
PATHWAYS SHOW THAT YOU CAN
RECREATE SAFELY. AND SECOND OF
ALL THERE WAS LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR THAT SAYS WHEN WE DO THAT
KIND OF DAMAGE WE MITIGATE. SO
WE TAKE CARE OF IT LATER R. O.
H. B. PARKS ARE THE CLEANEST
EXAMPLE OF HOW H. B. RECREATION
SHOULD BE DONE. THE SECOND
REASON WERE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. IS THAT IT SETS A VERY
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT. PARKS DID
EVERYTHING THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
PARK COULD BE USED FOR OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION.
MANY OF THOSE WHO OPPOSE THE
BILL WHO ARE SUPPORT THIS BILL
IN A PROPOSAL A TV AT THE TIME.
THAT IT WAS SET ASIDE FOR A WAY
TO BE RECREATION TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF THE PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY GOT RIGHT OF WAYS FOR
THEIR OWN PROPERTY. THEY MADE
SURE THAT THE VERY WOULD TAKEN
CARE OF AND NOW THEY OPPOSE THE
IDEA OF HAVING IT IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD. IF YOU ALLOW THIS
BILL TO GO THROUGH EVERY SINGLE
TIME STATE PARKS SETS ASIDE A
PARK FOR A PARTICULAR REASON.
AN EXCELLENT LEGISLATOR CAN
STEP FORWARD AND SAY WE DON'T
WANT TO DO IT IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD WE WANT TO REVISIT
THE PROCESS WE WANT INEXPENSIVE
X. EXHAUSTIVE RE VISIT. OF AN
ISSUE IT'S A BAD IDEA IT'S A
BAD PRECEDENT WHICH HE HAS DONE
EVERYTHING THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
IT'S AN AREA THAT THAT WORKS
FOR H. B. RECREATION IN AGAIN
ONLY EIGHT OF THE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PARKS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME YOU SEE AND WHAT.
CITY WHAT WAS THE THIRD THING
CRAVEN TOLD YOU DO BECAUSE A
BRIEF FOR OUR EXPLORATION LASER
AND THEN YOU LET THIRD ALL THE
THIRD THING WAS TO ASK THAT YOU
NOT VOTE FOR THIS. HE HE DIDN'T
SAY. IT WAS IN HIS. THIRTIES
HAD TO DO A CLOSE UNDERSTOOD
VERY GOOD THERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. OKAY MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE JAMES
EMBARRASSING ON BEHALF OF THE
BETA CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
USERS. AND THE CALIFORNIA MOTOR
DO MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION. THAT SELL AND
SERVICE THE MOTORCYCLES AND THE
EQUIPMENT TO BE USED. AND
TERREUS ELOQUENTLY OUTLINED OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL
BRING IT BACK WE'RE GONNA STEPS
QUORUM NOW THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR BEING HERE SO JUST TAKE
PAUSE FOR A BRIEF MOMENT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE CENTERS TURN
HERE. JONES JUST PRESENT ALLEN
FORGES CABALLERO COMING OVER
HERE HERTZBERG HUESO. HUESO
HERE JACKSON MONEY MONEY HERE.
VERY GOOD WE HAVE A QUORUM
MEMBERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE A YES SEE ONE. WELL
I WILL I WILL MAKE THE COMMENT
BECAUSE I. THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION THE LAST TIME IN
AND I'LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT AT
THIS THIS BILL DID CAUSE ME
SOME PAUSE FOR EXACTLY THE
REASON THAT WITH ARTICULATED BY
THE OPPOSITION YEAH AND I AM
STRUCK BY THE. I'M STRUCK BY
THE COMMENT THAT. YOU KNOW WE
SUPPORT HD BUT NOT HERE IT'S A
LITTLE BIT SIMILAR TO THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE LIKE TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE SUPPORTED BUT NOT
HERE AND THEN IT BECOMES NOT
REALLY ANYWHERE. A SO MY
CONCERN IS THAT IT MAY MAKE IT
IT MAY BE APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW DO WE CREATE
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE WRITERS OF H. B. VEHICLES
H. VEHICLES ALL OVER THE STATE
SO THAT IF WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
WE'RE NOT ASKING THEM TO DRIVE
SIX HOURS TO GO SOME PLACE. TO
BE ABLE TO RECREATION FOR A
COUPLE OF HOURS AND THEN THEY
HAVE TO DRIVE SIX HOURS BACK
AND I SAID I'M I'M I I'M NOT
AND I KNOW EACH BE ENTHUSIAST.
WHO'S GOT TIME BUT- BUT BUT I
DO HAVE STAFF HI CHAU IT'S
LIKE. HIS WOULD BE GREAT TAKE
ME OUT. ESPECIALLY ON A DAY
LIKE TODAY. BUT BUT I KNOW
PEOPLE THAT THAT THAT ARE AND
WHAT THEY TELL ME IS THAT THEY
REALLY HAVE TO TRAVEL A LONG
DISTANCE IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO. TO ENJOY THE SPORT AND TO
ME AND IT'S A IT'S A FAMILY
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITY AND
YOU CAN TAKE YOUR KIDS THAT ARE
AT AT A VERY YOUNG AGE. AND
SPEND TIME TOGETHER AND I THINK
THAT'S WE WANT THAT AND SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS A- I'D
A DISTRICT BELL AND I RESPECT
THAT AND I AM. I'M I'M I'M AN
EXPERT ABOUT TODAY BUT I AM A
LITTLE BIT TROUBLED BY THE
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT THAT WE ARE
SITTING WHICH IS TO PICK AND
CHOOSE AND DECIDE. YOU KNOW
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO OVER RULE
THAT WISE WE GIVE THAT THE
AUTHORITY DID THAT TO OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND AT SOME POINT
WE NEED TO. THEN LISTEN TO THEM
SO. THOUGHT FOR A- UNDERSTOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH A- STRUCTURE.
LARA I JUST I WANT TO START OFF
BY SAYING THAT SENATOR COVER
YOUR JUST RUINED MY DAY. I
THOUGHT I WAS IN H. B.
ENTHUSIAST AND THEN I JUST
REALIZED I HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO
DO IT. SO MAYBE I'M NOT ANYMORE
AND MAYBE NEED TO RECONSIDER
THAT BUT I HAVE NOW THAT SHE
HAS SAID THAT WHEN I GET HOME.
I'VE GOT SEVERAL EACH BE PARKS
IN MY AREA THAT I WILL I GET TO
NOW. BUT THERE DO YOU WANT TO
SHARE SOME. SERIOUS CONCERNS
FOR THE TRADITIONS OF THE
SENATE AND THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR YOU KNOW FIRST OF
ALL THE TRADITIONS IN PRACTICE
OF THE LEGISLATURE AT LEAST THE
SENATE USED TO BE THE BILL'S
TELLING COMMITTEE OF THE OTHER
HOUSE WOULD NOT ALL OF A SUDDEN
BE PUT INTO A LAKE GOTTEN
AMEND. AND YOU KNOW HERE WE ARE
IN THE LAST THREE DAYS OF
SESSION AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
WE'RE WE WANT TO VIOLATE THAT
TRADITION SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
WHICH IT WAS AND I DIFFICULT IS
MAJOR WAS HELD IN THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND I
WOULD ARGUE APPROPRIATELY. THAT
SHOULD BE THE END OF IT WE
SHOULDN'T EVEN BE HERE
LISTENING TO THIS A LAST MINUTE
GOTTEN AMEND. WE EITHER HAVE
TRADITIONS AND IN THE SENATE
THAT WE'RE GONNA LIVE BY RULES
AND PRACTICES. OR I'VE AFRAID
TO THAT THE SENATE IS GIVING UP
A PORTION OF ITS INTEGRITY. BY
HAVING THIS COME UP AT SUCH A
LATE TIME. SECONDLY AND MORE TO
THE POINT OF THE BILL OF THE
POLICY IMPLICATIONS HAS HAS
BEEN SHARED ALREADY THIS
MORNING ARE EXTREMELY
PROBLEMATIC. THE AREA
ENCOMPASSED BY THIS BILL WAS
PURCHASED WITH OAG FUNDS AND IT
IS SUPPOSED TO BE USED FOR HV
PURPOSES. THE STATE WILL BE
GOING OUT BACK ON ITS
COMMITMENT ONCE AGAIN AND I'M
AFRAID THAT THE PRESIDENT WILL
BE SET AND I JUST DID NOT SET
THAT PRESIDENT THAT THIS LAND
WAS APPROPRIATELY PURCHASED
PROPERLY PLANNED. AND I THINK
ONE OF THE OTHER POINTS I'D
LIKE TO DRIVE. A LITTLE BIT
EVEN MOREAS THE MITIGATION ON
THESE TYPES OF PARKS. WELL I'VE
BEEN IN A LOT OF THEM AND I
AGREE WITH THAT MR MCHALE THAT.
THE R. O. H. V. PARKS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE PRISTINE AND-
WHAT THAT WOULD WITH THESE
ALWAYS FREE PARKS I THINK
SOMETIMES YOU LOSE THE FOCUS ON
THAT ON. WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE
WITH THE WHICH HE PARKS. IS IT
WE PLAN THEM WE PUT THEM IN A
PARTICULAR PART OF THE STATE.
THEY PROVIDE A RECREATION
AVENUE FOR FOLKS OUR STATE IN
IS CENTER COPIER POINTED OUT WE
DON'T WANT PEOPLE DRIVING SIX
HOURS. TO GET TO THESE
RECREATION AREAS. ARE AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU BUILD AND- ANNOYS ME
PARK LIKE THIS THAT'S MANAGED
PROPERLY THIS PLAN THE PEOPLE
GOING USE IT. AND THEN IT TAKES
THE PRESSURE OFF. OTHER
PROPERTY OTHER LAND THAT IS NOW
ABLE TO MAINTAIN ITS MOST
PRISTINE. AB SITUATION BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE ILLEGALLY OFF
ROADING NOW I'M NOT MAKING AN
EXCUSE FOR PEOPLE TO GO
ILLEGALLY OFFROAD I I'VE I
ABSOLUTELY DO NOT SUPPORT THAT.
BUT WHEN WE WHEN WE GIVE THEM.
PROPERLY MANAGED IN PLAN AREAS
TO GO TO IT DECREASES THE
AMOUNT OF ILLEGAL ACTIVITY IN
THOSE AREAS AND. AND WHAT
NINETY NINE POINT 9% OF OFF
ROADERS WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND GO TO THE RIGHT
PLACES AND IN JOY THEIR STATE
AND SO I AM HOPEFUL THAT THE
THIS COMMITTEE WILL TURN THIS
BILL DOWN AND THAT WILL GET
THIS ALWAYS THREE PARK PROPERLY
BUILT. AND USED FOR PEOPLE
DIRECTORY IN THAT AREA THE
STATE THANKS VERY MUCH OKAY
THANK YOU MISS RICE FOR OTHERS
YES THERE WAS A JUST GENERALLY
AND THIS BILL DOESN'T HAVE A
PROVISION THAT REQUIRES. IF
THIS LAND IS SOLD THAT'D BE
REPLACED WITH ANOTHER
RECREATION AREA. I IMAGINE IF
THIS IS SOLD FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
PURPOSES IF THEY- HAVE FOUND
THAT THERE IS ENORMOUS BAR
BERMAN VALLEY IN THIS LAND AND
IT IS SOLD. IS THERE A
REQUIREMENT THAT THIS ASSET BE
REPLACED IN TERMS OF ANOTHER
RECREATIONAL AREA. BECAUSE I
DON'T SEE THAT IN IN IN THE
ANALYSIS SAID THE BILL DOESN'T
REQUIRE. ANYTHING OF THE STATE
PARKS IS PURELY GIVES STATE
PARKS THE RIGHT TO SELL THE
LAND FOR AT LEAST AS MUCH AS IT
WAS PURCHASED FOR. SO TO GET
THEIR MONEY BACK I UNDERSTAND
THAT MONEY GOES BACK TO BE
OFFERED VEHICLE PORTION TO USE
AS THEY WELL WE'RE NOT
MANDATING HOW STATE PARKS WILL
DO THAT BUT- I IMAGINE THEY
WOULD USE IT TO CREATE OFFERED
VEHICLE OPPORTUNITIES BUT I
WANT TO. ALSO SAY THAT YOU KNOW
SENATOR GLAZER AND HIS DRAFTING
OF THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS
BILL WAS THOUGHTFUL IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OFFERED FOR
LEGAL OFFERED VEHICLE NEXT
DOOR. I MEAN CONTINUOUS WITH
THIS LAND THERE IS LEGAL
OPPORTUNE DE THE NOBODY IS
TOUCHING. AND WE CAN TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHY THIS
IS SO IMPORTANT. AND IT IS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
MAP OF THE DIABLO RANGE. WHICH
COMES OFF MOUNT DIABLO IN DOWN
THE STATE THIS IS A PINCH POINT
FOR THE ANIMALS THAT ARE
MIGRATING. AND WHEN WE TURN
THIS INTO AN OFFERED VEHICLE
PARK WE WILL CLOSE THAT
MIGRATION PATTERNS. AND
CURRENTLY THIS PIECE OF THE
LAND IS USED BY THOSE ANIMALS.
AND AGAIN THERE'S IN
NEIGHBORING PIECE OF LAND THEY
ARE LEGALLY ALLOWED TO AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ALLOWED TO.
RECORD ON THEY WON'T HAVE TO
DRIVE ANY FURTHER THAN THEY
CURRENTLY DRIVE. BUT YOU KNOW
THIS PIECE OF LAND LIKE YOU
SAID HAS INCREDIBLE. IMPORTANCE
TO THE BIODIVERSITY OF THE
DIABLO RANGE AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE THIS PIECE
BUT OF COURSE THEY HAVE THE
MONEY THEY WILL HAVE THE MONEY
RETURNED TO THEM. TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. YOU
KNOW I WOULD BE MORE
COMFORTABLE SUPPORT. THE BILL
SHOULD THERE BE SOME. I'M
PLACE. AND WORK ON TERMS OF A
REQUIREMENT OF. THE IN EITHER A
NEARBY ORIGINATION AREAS THIS
P. REPLACES PART OF KIND OF THE-
MAIN ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
IS VERY IMPORTANT AND IF THIS
IS BEEN FOUND TO HAVE ENORMOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL VALUE I THINK
THAT SHOULD. DOT THAT SHOULD
TAKE PRECEDENCE HOWEVER. IN
REGARDS TO THESE RECREATION
AREAS I'VE ALWAYS NOTED THAT
HAVE BEEN. AN AREA WHERE PEOPLE
WOULD RECREATION WILL WOULD
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE DON'T. OF. I
DON'T INTEND TO DON'T TRY TO
RECREATION AREAS THAT ARE
SENSITIVE HABITAT WHERE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE RECREATION AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN A
PROBLEM IN MY DISTRICT BECAUSE
I HAVE A VERY LARGE DISTRICT
THAT OCCURRED AT THAT INCLUDES
SOME SOME VERY IMPORTANT BARMAN
HABITAT THAT AFFECTS CERTAIN
SPECIES THAT ARE OF THREATENED
AND- ENDANGERED. AND PEOPLE
JUST GO OUT THERE RECREATION
BECAUSE THEY DON'T THEY HAVE
VERY VERY LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES
AND SOME VERY LARGE GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS. WHERE YOU CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND MAKE IT
ACCESSIBLE THEY'RE LESS LIKELY
TO GO OUT INTO THE OPEN SPACE
AND ENVIRONMENT AND CAUSE HARM.
AND SO ANY CHANCE THAT WE CAN
DO THAT THAT. HAS ENVIRONMENTAL
VALUE AND IF IT'S WORKED INTO A
PLAN. THAT COULD WE COULD
ENSURE THAT. ONCE YOU SELL THIS
LANNISTER TO TRY TO DEVELOP
ANOTHER THE SAME PEOPLE THAT.
HELP YOU ACQUIRE IS LOUDER THAN
OPPOSE THAT MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE STATE TO REPLACE THE
SASSER UNLESS IT'S UNLESS IT'S
PART. OF AN AGREEMENT THAT
SHOULD THIS LAND BE SOLD THAT
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO PUT THOSE
MONIES IN THOSE FUNDS BECAUSE
THOSE FUNDS COULD BE RIGHT UP.
IN LAWSUITS. OF FOR YEARS AND
I'VE SEEN THAT HAPPEN WITH.
URBAN PROJECTS LIBRARIES AND
PARKS AND THINGS LIKE THAT TO
GET. HELD UP IN IN LITIGATION
FOR YEARS. THROUGH KIND OF THE
SEQUEL PROCESS OF SEQUEL WE
WANT TO WE WANT USED TO PROTECT
LAND BUT IT'S OFTEN SICK WAS
OFTEN ABUSED. AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT WITH REGARD TO THIS
MEASURE THROUGH THE CHAIR
CENTER. PLEASE I'M STILL
ACTIVATIONS THAT CENTER HUESO
ONE IS THAT THE OFF ROAD
VEHICLE COMMISSION. MADE OF
ENTHUSIASTS AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND REC ARE IN CHARGE
HERE NOT THAT NOTHING IN THIS
BILL CHANGES THAT THEY GET TO
DECIDE WHAT'S BEST. FOR THIS
PROJECT OR TO LET MAKE A
DECISION THAT MAYBE WOULD BE
BEST TO SELL THE LAND OKAY SO
THEY THEY REMAIN IN CHARGE NOW
AND IN THE FUTURE. SECOND THING
IS THAT ANY MONEY THAT'S
DEPOSITED BACK INTO THE H. B.
FIND BY LAW IS RESTRICTED IN
ITS USE. UNLESS WE CHANGE THE
LAW IT HAS TO BE A PROVIDED FOR
THAT ACTIVITY WHEREVER IT'S DE
DESIGNATED TO BE USED FOR AS I
MENTIONED I WANTED TO BE USED
FOR THAT ACTIVITY NOT TRY TIED
UP AND LAWSUITS WELL THAT'S OF
COURSE THE PROBLEM THAT THEY'RE
FACING TODAY. IS THAT THE LAND
IS TIED UP IN WHAT. AND THAT
THE- DEPARTMENT DOES AN OPTION
TODAY IF THEY SAID WE WERE
SPENDING MILLIONS ON THE
LAWYERS. THIS DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE THERE'S ALREADY OFF ROAD%
RIGHT THERE. A MINUTE AWAY THAT
PEOPLE CAN USE WITH DECLINING.
ATTENDANCE SO WE CAN STILL
MAINTAIN THAT ACTIVITY RIGHT
THERE IN THE AREA FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ENJOYING IT.
BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
SPEND MILLIONS IN LAWYER FEES
NOW. WHEN WE CAN CUT OUR LOSSES
AND FIND ANOTHER PLACE THAT'S
MORE AMENABLE FOR THIS
ACTIVITY. SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL PROVIDES THAT ONLY THAT
OPTION. UP TO DO EXACTLY WHAT I
THINK YOU'RE ENCOURAGING Là.
OKAY THANK YOU OTHER MEMBERS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SEEING NONE.
BY YOU ALL TO CLOSE AYE AYE I
WOULD JUST SAY VERY BRIEFLY
YEAH THE RESTRICTED USE UNDER
CURRENT LAW ON THAT IT WHICH WE
TRUST FUND HOPEFULLY WILL
SETTLE SOME OF THESE ISSUES I
SHARE SOME OF THE ENTHUSIASM OF
MY VICE CHAIR ACTUALLY. RAMBLED
AROUND ENOUGH TO LOW WELLS AND
AT SOME HAIRY EXPERIENCES IN
THE SLOT CANYONS ON MY OWN HV
ADVENTURES. AND THIS WEEK I
KNOCKED HILL WELLS OUT IN.
SORRY I'M A GRINGO. LOCAL DEAL
WELL OKAY THE SYMPTOMS. AND I
THINK LOCAL LOCAL CONTROL AND
SORT OF THIS THIS LOCAL INPUT
IS CRITICAL SO HEARING FROM
YOUR SUPERVISOR AND YOU KNOW
SORT OF THE COUNTY AS WELL AS
LOCAL MEMBERS IS COMPELLING IN
THIS CASE IN TERMS OF
DETERMINING WHAT USES OUR BEST
IN YOUR BACKYARD AND NOT JUST
SAYING NO BUT SAYING WHERE AND
SERVER THAT REASONABLY SUPPORT
THE MEASURE TODAY AND
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT BACK
IN ITS TERMS A PROCESS YOU KNOW
I CAN ONLY COMMENT ON THE
POLICY COMMITTEE HERE IN TERMS
OF HOW THE PROCEDURAL RULES
COMMITTEE. PROCESS GOES ISN'T
IS A LITTLE BIT OF MY PAY GRADE
BUT AS A POLICY MATTER I THINK
IT'S SOUND AND WELL BAKED AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRING AFFORD TO
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
I'M- YES I URGE YOU ALL TO JOIN
US OUT IN OUR DISTRICTS TO GO
TO CARNEGIE AND ENJOY THE
OFFERED VEHICLE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE THERE AND THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE THERE FOR THOSE
AND AS SENATOR JOHN SAID MOST
IF NOT ALL USES LEGALLY AND
STAY ON THAT LAND AND SO YOU
KNOW WE LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT THE LAND NEXT DOOR AT
THAT TIME THE ANIMALS SO
DESPERATELY NEEDS OUR- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ISLAND.
OKAY VERY GOOD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
PLEASE CALL TH ROLL. CENTER
STERN AYE STERN AYE JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN. FORGES HEAVIER.
HEAVIER AYE HERTZBERG. HUESO
HUESO AYE JACKSON. JACKSON I
MONEY. MONNING HI THE BILL HAS.
OKAY THAT DOESN'T OF BOATS THE
PAST WE ARE WE MISSING ANY
MEMBERS. ALLEN I THINK WE'LL
JUST MOVE THE BILL OUT AND
CLOSE THE ROLE AT THIS POINT
AND MOVE IT TO SO THAT BILLS AT
FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU ALL. THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED OKAY. YEAH
I JUST. DID IT